drive and breathe into his nostrils the
breath of life and man became a living soul
look clearly at that verse and there are two
processes that are carried out the lord god
formed man of the dust of the ground that
was one process he formed him or one step
he formed man from the substance of the
earth clay dirt ground earth different
terms the bible uses for the same concept then
he breathed into his nostrils the breath of life
so we have the substance from
the earth that's physical
and that's from beneath then we have
something from above let's call that spiritual
and while the spiritual aspect was absent
the physical had no meaning it had
no life but it was beautifully formed
the bible says in first timothy chapter 5 verse
6 she that liveth for pleasure is dead while she
liveth because the life of god is not in that
person she or he i am saying while the spiritual
was up above not yet breathed into the
physical the physical was just lifeless
god wants us to understand very early in
scripture that there is an unbreakable connection
between the physical and the spiritual and
whenever that connection is damaged or harmed both
suffer the ill effects and so god breathed
into his nostrils the breath of life
and man became a living soul something
from beneath something from above
and god's ideal for his people is that his
people will enjoy the highest expression of life
when they understand that his desire for them
is a combination of something from beneath that
physical and something from above that spiritual
and that combination must not be tampered with
genesis chapter 1 we see another example of the
physical depending on that which is outside it
and beyond it it was never god's plan that
earth and that which is a part of earth
exists separately from that which comes from
heaven genesis chapter 1 verse 14 and god said
let there be light in the firmament of the
heaven to divide the day from the night
and let them be for signs and for
seasons and for days and years
and let them be for lights in the firmament
of the heaven to give light upon the earth
and god created great light two great lights the
greater light to rule the day and the lesser light
to rule the night he made the stars also now let
us examine that information here is the earth
and god says let there be light swear in
the firmament of the heaven not on the earth
in the firmament and so god made the sun the sun
is above god made this moon the moon is above
god made the stars the stars are above and
the point one of the many points we can
learn from this is that earth must depend
on an outside source for all its light
are you following god's word we are dependent on a
source outside of ourselves for light now we know
from john 1 verse 4 in him was life and the life
was the light of men light is a symbol of life
life comes from above
this flesh is not life strictly
speaking it is an expression of the life
because if god withdraws
the life this still remains
someone tells me that the hair takes
a long time before it decomposes if
it ever does i'm not sure bones remain
thousands of years but the life is gone
the life comes from above that i prefer to call
today as the spiritual aspect of the person no
aspect of us is more important than the spiritual
and god desires that we will in everything
we do remember that there is the spiritual
and there is the physical and the bond
the connection must remain unbroken
moving from the connection between the spiritual
and the physical let's go to genesis chapter two
let's stay in chapter one read
from verse 29 then we'll go to two
verse 29 genesis one of the lord god said behold
i have given you every herb bearing seed which
is upon the face of all the earth and every tree
in the witch is the fruit of a tree yielding sea
to you it shall be from meat and to every beast of
the earth and every fowl of the air and everything
that creepeth upon the earth wherein there is
life i have given every green herb for what for me
now god gives clear instructions to
adam regarding the diet he should follow
now he simply tells him in verse
2 of chapter verse 15 of chapter 2
and the lord god took the man and put him
into the garden to dress it and to keep it
he gives no details about how
to dress it nor how to keep
but he goes into detail as to what adam
and eve should eat because eating is an
expression of holiness you read leviticus 11
that very popular chapter where all the foods
that should be eaten are listed and those that
should not be eaten enlisted you read from verse
44 down to the end of that chapter you will
see that god concludes i say ye must be holy
because i am holy let me tell you something health
habits are a clear expression of sanctification
it is not enough to leave the environs
of this church and then head for some
restaurant and eat without the consciousness
that i am a holy being my holiness must affect
how i make my selections whether in a restaurant
or at my home my holiness must affect me
and so many of us are sick i say because we
have violated god's laws for healthful living
and health living is not strictly
physical it is a combination
of healthy physical and healthy spiritual
let me repeat with sympathy as your brother
in christ and in trials and tribulation
as john said the church is your brother and
companion in tribulation and in the patience
and kingdom of jesus christ as you are so am
i as i said to the congregation this morning
people in my position carry a heavy burden because
we're speaking about standards to people and we
are no different from they are so sometimes we
feel so hypocritical but we have to do the work
god requires that our religion be
expressed in every aspect of our lives
how we dress affects our health
any amends let me say it again how we
dress affects our health where we live
affects our health
how we breathe affects our health
how much of a good thing we eat affects our health
health is first and foremost a spiritual matter
because it is rooted in the sixth
commandment thou shalt not kill
and many people kill themselves slowly
by how they eat and how they drink
and how much pressure they
put themselves under for no
good reason other than perhaps money and prestige
destroying the temple of god which he has given to
us and as i read to the congregation this morning
patriots and prophets page 45 paragraph
2 man was made to bear god's image
in outward resemblance and in character we
must look like god but if we let our bodies go
disregard our health
we confuse people as to what a true christian is
a true christian doesn't only wear long dresses
or long shirts a true christian
is one who understands
and realizes and let me add to the
a true prophetic end time christian
is one who understands that the right
arm of the gospel is one health message
now let's go to exodus chapter 15. we may come
back to genesis 2. exodus 15 he's 28 after five
i want to be finished by 5 45. exodus chapter 15
here is what god promises the israelites can god
lie numbers 23 19 god is not a man that he should
lie here is the truth the whole truth nothing
but the truth exodus 15 26 and said if thou wilt
diligently hearten unto the voice of the lord thy
god and will do that which is right in his sight
and will keep his commandments and give ear to all
his statutes i will put none of these diseases
upon you that i have brought upon the egyptians
i am the lord that does what the healeth thee now
there are people who accuse faithful christians of
fanaticism just because the faithful christian
has decided anything god tells me to do i'll do
let's read that verse again if thou wilt
diligently hearken to the voice of the
lord thy god what does diligently mean carefully
you know when you're studying for final
exam that's what i mean by diligently
you're doing some research that
will put you in line for tenure
that's what i mean by diligently you just
finished your phd dissertation you're about to
present it to your committee that's what i mean by
diligently if thou wilt diligently hearken to whom
the voice of the lord thy god not
the advertising slogans of mcdonald's
or wendy's and her cousins
but if thou will diligently hearken to the voice
of the lord thy god and for the seventh-day
adventists the voice is god's word and i like
to think of ellen white's writings as the echo
and will do that which is
right in his sight not yours
not the food and drug administration
not the sugar industry
and will do that which is right in his
sight and will keep most of the commandments
and give ear to the overwhelming majority of his
statutes you know god is an all or nothing god
i told you that maybe last week he's all
or nothing you can't serve god on layaway
now god says if you'll do
that look at the four things
they're all related if thou will diligently
hearken to the voice of the lord thy god
and will do that which is right in his
sight and keep all his commandments
and gives ear to all his statutes now is
that fanaticism or is that strict obedience
a few years ago a friend of mine was writing
an article for one of the churches publications
so i got a call from the friend can you help
me with the article fine we worked on it
it was submitted for publication
it was supposed to be an article on love
i think and in the article my friend wrote
we must maintain strict we
must give god strict obedience
to remain in his love something like that very
similar to john 15 10 if you keep my commandments
you shall abide in my love as i've kept my
father's commandments and abide in his love
the editor contacted my friend
and said we cannot publish this
if you will take out strict
obedience we'll publish it
we're trying to preach love not legalism that's
what my friend was told there is something in the
church that causes members to react almost
allergically to the expression straight
obedience now there's a simple explanation for
that romans 8 7 because the carnal mind is enmity
against god for it is not subject to
the law of god neither indeed can be
but if we will diligently hearken to the
voice of the lord thy god and will do
that which is right in his sight and keep his
commandments and give ear to all his statutes
god has promised with heaven and earth as
witnesses i will put how many diseases none
now let's think none
upon you that i have brought upon the egyptians
i am the lord that healeth me do you see the
connection between health and obedience to god
let's go to exodus 23 verse 25. by the
way the subject is lose weight find life
i promise to do this later
next week but i'm doing it now
exodus 23 verse 25 moses speaking for
god and ye shall serve the lord your god
god shall bless thy bread and thy water and i
will take sickness away from the midst of you
no lie but notice the first line of verse 25
exodus 23 and ye shall do what serve now what does
it mean to serve the lord your god let me show
you go to deuteronomy uh joshua 24 24 joshua 24 24
here we have it the bible says and
all the people said unto joshua
the lord our god will we do what serve
and his voice will be what obey now those
two expressions are virtually the same
thing to serve god is to what obey god
that's why when the devil came to jesus and said
all these will i give thee if thou will fall down
and worship me jesus said it is written thou shalt
worship the law of thy god and him only shall thou
serve the highest expression of
worship is plain and simple obedience
not the size of your pipe organ i love
pipe organs not how much the carpet cost
although we ought to give god the best that temple
in jerusalem was the most magnificent building of
its time but jesus left it and you shall serve the
lord your god health comes from a spiritual source
obedience to god let's go to psalm 103 reading
verses 1 to 3. psalm 103 verses 1 2 and 3
bless the lord o my soul and all
that is within me bless his holy name
bless the lord o my soul and forget not all his
benefits read verse 3 with me if you have the
king james version nice and loud who forgiveth all
thine iniquities who healeth most of thy diseases
but what's the line before heal thy
diseases what does it say who forgiveth
spiritual health and physical health
are siamese twins joined at the heart
let's go to james chapter 5 25
minutes to 6 according to that clock
james 5 reading from verse 14.
is any sick among you let him call for the
elders of the church to let them pray over him
anointing him with oil in the name
of the lord and the prayer of faith
shall save the sick and the lord shall raise
him up now read the next part with me and if
he hath what committed sins here again we have
physical healing with what spiritual restoration
they cannot be separated because
sickness is the result of sin
my favorite bible writer who is that hello
height she said the devil is the originator of
sickness he didn't say this but i'm saying it we
cooperate with the devil too much and we fall sick
a sick person cannot serve
god like a healthy person
you're following me i don't
care how much desire you have
an army with six soldiers will lose that war
soldiers are to be on the
battlefield not in sickbay
and we must feel a moral ten
commandment obligation to be in the best
fighting shape we can regardless of age
how old was moses when he died how
much arthritis did he have none
what does the bible say of moses
when he died his eyesight was
he didn't need this and his physical strength
undiminished now does god play favorites
no that's god's desire for people on
the very brink of the promised land
jesus did more healing than preaching
but every healing miracle was designed to teach
the spiritual lesson that god desires to heal us
spiritually so sometimes he said
thy sins be forgiven thee first
that's where the problem lies god is not concerned
primarily with symptoms he's concerned with
causes because causes lead to effects you nip
the cause in the bud you do not have to spend
money on the effect too many people get rich
off dealing with effects let's keep the money
in the church go build some schools in africa
and some churches in asia and some small ellen
white clinics in philippines and something where
people have need not like us we don't know what
to do with our money let let's keep it and
send it to our brothers overseas somewhere
thou shalt not kill
my beloved brothers and sisters i'll
ask you a question don't answer me
are we killing ourselves by the way we eat
i have i know someone that may be safe you
never know where these tapes go i know someone
who needs to make some changes in what goes
into that person's mouth and just will not do it
we don't understand that when
satan came into the garden of eden
he did not tempt eve to slap adam spousal abuse
he didn't do that
he came to her on the ground of appetite is
appetite the same no was eve made with appetite
was she made perfect was adam made perfect did
he have an appetite yes but the devil has this
uncanny ability to induce us to take that which
god has given us for our blessing and his glory
and misuse it for the devil's credit and
we ought to apologize to god for them
an open and free apology god is so merciful and
god is so great that when he designed this body
he designed it so well that even after 6 000
years of the ravages of sin the immune system
is still so vigorous and robust that it can
deal with just about anything for a while
and then it breaks down like any other machine
in no other way do we damage ourselves more
than in our eating habits our health habits
the devil came to adam and eve through appetite
and when something works for
satan he doesn't change it
i don't want to follow his example
but you can't blame him for that
love works for god so he doesn't try another
strategy and i have amens on this side
so when jesus began his public ministry matthew
4 verse 1 then was jesus led up of the spirit
into the wilderness to be tempted of the devil
and after it fasted 40 days and 40 nights he
was afterward and hungered and when the tempter
came he said unto him if thou be the son of god
command that these stones be made bread same
temptation in that it appealed to appetite
now it's one thing to tend to man who hasn't eaten
since four o'clock today quarter to six hour and
15 minutes you can't die but to tempt a man in
the area of appetite who has not eaten for 40 days
but jesus knew that this is the avenue to the soul
with the largest door if the devil can open it
and through it he and his demons don't
file one by one they come in as a crowd
the avenue of appetite which should be kept locked
and the key place in the hand of
sanctified reasons somebody saying
appetite through us out
victory over appetite in jesus will get us back in
you know eating is important to god
now in the new world which will be right here
we still have the tree of life revelation 22 verse
1 and verse 2. in the midst of the street of it
and on either side of the river was there the
tree of life which yielded 12 million fruits
and bear the fruit every month and the leaves of
the tree were for the healing of the nation the
tree of life will be there with 12 mana of fruit
whether they're 12 different fruits each month
or each month there's one fruit different from
the other i'm not sure and i really don't care
in the new world we can't
die but we still have to eat
are you following me there is something critically
important about eating god desires that throughout
eternity we will maintain our immortality
through eating from the tree of life
we will maintain it because no
one is immortal independent of god
not even immortality is a self-contained reality
you have to depend on god for continuing
immortality through the tree of life
now god uses eating he moves it from
the physical he doesn't detach it
he just slides it up to the spiritual and
jesus says eat my flesh and drink my blood
john 6 63 let me tell you something in john
6 53 jesus said verily verily i say unto you
except he eat the flesh of the son of man and
drink his blood ye have what no life now when
jesus said that was he speaking to living people
yes so what did he mean by no life no eternal life
eternal life is in god's word
i didn't say it's in the ink of the people eternal
life is in god's word now understanding that
we are born again by god's word james 1 18 of
his own will begat he us by the word of truth
being born again not of corruptable but of
incorruptible seed by the word of god which
liveth in a bible forever we are converted
by the word of god as much as the world was
created by the word of god god functions by his
word now i need to do everything under the sun
to be sure i understand this life-giving word
how i eat affects how i understand
how i eat affects whether i'm irritable
or pleasant how i eat affects if my
animal passions will rage out of control
health
health is not the business of some
hmo health is the business of god
and all the counsel we need is here and amplified
in the writings of my favorite writer who's that
alan why can you say amen for ellen why that woman
is something else or was something else still
continues to be something else through her writing
i was reading councils on health today and i had
to make sure no one saw the embarrassed look on my
face when i ran some of the things she said to me
i wish i could recall this quotation
i don't remember where i saw it
this means i'm coming to the end
she said the devil knows i'm going to step
down so mr cameraman just want to warn you
alan white says and you can find it the devil
knows if we gain the victory over appetite every
other temptation is easier to resist
now do i need a greater
motivation to watch my health
then if we are sitting here or standing here and
we know in the privacy the inner sanctum of our
soul there is some vice i have wrestled with for
years maybe we should begin the remedial activity
in the area of the appetite
there are rapists in prisons for life because
they could not control the animal passion
the people who wasted their lives
misspent their vital energies
because they could not control the lower
passions which were put there by god
god invented appetite
for our enjoyment but as i said to the place
under the control of a sanctified reason
as you said it's 10 minutes to six i must move
on as we assemble here i want you to think
the miracle working power of god
is not to be seen as an atm machine
god has a lifestyle we must
follow but sometimes god does
unusual things because he's god and we can't
really restrict him and tell him what to do
god has a lifestyle and the lifestyle is healthy
living that's the lifestyle he desires for us
if we would follow it as a people sickness
would not characterize us as it does now
despite our claims based on research
that we're the healthiest people in the
world but sometimes god does
remarkable things as he always has
but it's essential that you and
i make a pledge here today god
i will begin to take my health seriously
as a matter of spiritual life and death
many people cannot understand the
prophecies because of how we eat
not because the words are
long or they don't know hebrew
the enlightenment god desires to send is blocked
because the faculties for comprehension and
reasoning are numb and deadened and decaying
and lifeless based on constant
bombardment from a faulty diet
so god's greater desire is not to perform a
miracle on your kidney but perform a miracle
on your will that you may choose to obey him
and then see the blessings flow like niagara
but god is so merciful psalm 103 verse 10 he hath
not dealt with us after our sins nor rewarded us
according to our iniquities you know if if god
would count sins who would stand who no one and
so we're coming today to bleep plead and beg for
mercy and to tell god father from this day on i by
your grace and a constant conviction of the holy
spirit will pay attention to my health practices
that i may be a walking billboard
for what a seventh-day adventist
prophetic time christian should be like
because the transformation that occurs in
the heart should be seen on the outside
let you i want you to think now if you and i know
try to focus on what i'm saying that we are now
as we sit and stand in violation of god's health
laws which are as sacred as the moral law
because they come from the moral if you know
i want you to make a pledge now say to god father
i apologize for disregarding one aspect of your
will for me and expecting you to do everything
else i want in this side of your will for me
i apologize for having a pick
and choose relationship with you
and i apologize for mistreating my body and in so
doing damaging my soul i want us if we are aware
of having done that to apologize to god today
now if that fits you i want you to stand there
now we will pray
we will pray
we'll pray quietly we will confess that
we have abused our bodies by our practices
lack of sleep no rest no
exercise no sunshine no fresh air
no water no trust in god whatever law of health
we have smashed to pieces we will apologize to god
after a quiet prayer and i will pray then
we'll move into the anointing praying
service for the sick every head bowed praying
quietly i'll give you a minute and a half
our father in heaven we bow in your presence
acknowledging you as god of heaven and earth
on a universal scale our personal
father on an intimate level
lord if it were not for your mercy we would
have been wiped off the face of the earth
with good cause father our heads and our
hearts are so hard we are so stubborn we
are determined to serve you our way father we
bring to you a repentant heart this afternoon
you cry out in deuteronomy 5 29 oh that there was
such a heart in them that they would fear me and
obey me i keep all my commandments always that it
may be well with them and their children forever
this is the heart you want and lord today to the
best of our abilities we give you a heart now
that is willing to obey you forgive us
for violating your sacred laws of health
and in so doing we have damaged the image that we
should reflect of you and by reflecting a partial
image we have confused those who need to see jesus
in us lord we have no idea perhaps how wide our
barefoot influence has spread and we can
only apologize in sackcloth and ashes today
oh lord we're sorry for the kinds of people we are
we're no different from the ancient israelites
but lord we want to be different and so we say
again we're sorry forgive us we apologize freely
and openly you are a god of mercy lord you do
not hold grudges wipe our sleep clean today
cast our sins of injurious health habits behind
your back and into the depths of the sea from
which they will not surface now lord give us a
converted heart that understands the physical
and the spiritual cannot be broken you said
it first peter 2 11 dearly beloved i beseech
you as strangers and pilgrims abstained from
fleshly lust which war against the soul the
things of the flesh they god they damage the soul
which is the spiritual and we have to understand
so lord whatever embarrassment we have caused
you by not being the people we should be
we are sorry all the occasions we have fallen to
the temptation of appetite and the lust of the
flesh and caused the devil to stick his finger
in your face and say see we apologize for that
sorry for hurting you and hurting you
and hurting you how can you take it god
but we we thank you for your eternal capacity to
take pain but we don't want to continue doing it
sorry father sorry my voice is the voice
of those gathered before you we are
sorry lord show that divine class that you have
and forgive us fully and freely let our hearts
be stirred by gratitude for bible says in first
john 4 19 we love him because he first loved us
we accept your forgiveness because you cannot lie
you've said if we confess our sins you're faithful
and just to forgive us of our sins and to cleanse
us from all unrighteousness so father we stand
now with a clean slate we do not deserve but for
which we thank you put your spirit into our hearts
the spirit that wrote the ten commandments the
spirit of obedience the spirit of love the spirit
of worship expressed in service and obedience
the very spirit of christ put it in us i pray
that through us lord you may receive henceforth
and forever glory glory glory as you are lived
out in our lives now lord as we enter into
the service special prayer for the sick
we ask that your will be done this
is not an expression of cowardice we
want your will to be done but father we
also want to tell you what we would like
because you said we've delight ourselves in the
lord he shall give us the desires of our hearts
father as i pray you've said you want others as
you will have them do unto you and i'm praying for
my afflicted brothers and sisters as i would have
them pray for me what we want father is relief
from our physical ailments what we want is
healing in our bodies oh lord do this for us
and we will try by the grace of god to let
our lives be an ongoing symphony of thanks
and praise to your holy name we don't want to play
with you god you're not a child we don't want to
toy with you we respect you for who you are we
fear you we're not afraid of you but we fear you
we reference you we honor you you are the god of
heaven and earth you are good god the father of
glory and we thank you for that now in the name
of jesus lord prepare our hearts for the service
as we move from one aspect to the next i offer
this prayer on behalf of your people and myself
in jesus name let all forgiven people say with
me amen and amen you may be seated you may be
seated but the norman would you
just help me uncover the table
okay during the service this past week
we announced the prayer for the sick and we made
some recommendations for spiritual preparation
which was if someone has offended you forgive
that person if you can reach the person
if you've sinned against
someone apologize to that person
if there's something in your life now that
you know is wrong confess it seek forgiveness
victory and deliverance these three were
essential the fasting was optional even
though i didn't say that if you have made
the preparations based on these three things
if you're also representing
someone i want you to stand
let me speak with brotherly clearness if you
have not made the preparations do not stand
what i will do judging on the numbers will
those in the bathroom please come down
come down now so we can be physically
together in a more precise way
and i hope their prayers
going up all over this place
service of this kind is not a spectator
sport we must always be in prayer please
we wait for our brothers and sisters to come down
come all the way down just occupy this
side over here that side over there
god bless you my kind sister some soft quiet
music maybe to god be the glory quietly
talking about how glorious he is it's a music of
expectation musical faith for what god will do
could you just come and stand to the left right
to the left yes those who came from the balcony
if there are any ministers in the congregation
could you come and stand with me please
so i'm not alone just come and stand with
me any pastors please come and stand with me
you need not do anything but i just need your
physical presence next to me god bless you
and i know i can count on you to pray quietly
if no one else does but i believe their prayers
going up from the congregation thank you very
much let's pray over the symbol just the symbol
our loving father as we're about to engage
in this service i present to you the symbol
of the spirit lord the symbol of the work that
should take place on our hearts hello white
writes your servant that the oil is a symbol
of the work of the holy spirit on our hearts
that's where it has to begin their god in the
heart meaning of course the mind so that our
decisions are right and our bodies can benefit we
offer this to you for this service we thank you
have invited us to do this now father demonstrate
your glory in our lives i pray in jesus name amen
i will ask those of you who are here
just say just come forward a little bit
i'll just briefly touch your
forehead according to james 5 14-15
you can step back please you can step back
i miss anyone did i miss anyone all right can i
have the first three rolls from here just
come down the center island come this way
first three rows
okay
mom
you can just step back slightly
i miss anyone here okay i guess they would plus
my sister can be seated right there somewhere
am i there to stay here make sure she's
seated for me please thank you very much
the first two rows here if you just
step forward as you align them the
second row just come and stand behind
thank you for those of you who are
praying
could you just step back let
those behind you step forward
okay those here you can return
to your seats and remain standing
next two rows back here just come forward
those of you here who came from the first two
rows you can return to your seats thank you
just two clear lines two clear lines
first leg come forward and forward
so the other leg can form behind you
hmm
would you just step back is there another
second no you're okay just return to your seats
can i miss anyone all right
the next two rows on this side please come forward
we should be done by 6 30 but we want
to do everything decently and in order
just come a little closer to me please
so someone grab my bible turn to exodus
chapter 20 and read the 10 commandments for us
right you may return to your seats exodus 20
is that microphone working
just read the ten commandments
let's have the next rows on
this side just come forward
hear the word of god and god spake
all these words saying i am the lord
thy god which have brought thee out of the
land of egypt out of the house of bondage
thou shalt have no other gods before me thou
shalt not make unto thee any graven image
or any likeness of anything
that is in heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath or
that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them nor
serve them by the lord thy god am i jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers upon the
children unto the third and fourth generation of
them that hate me and showing mercy unto thousands
of them that love me and keep my commandments
thou shall not take the name
of the lord thy god in vain
for the lord will not hold him
guiltless who takes his name in vain
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy six
days thou shall labor and do all thy work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of the lord
thy god in it thou shalt not do any work thou
know thy son nor thy daughter thy manservant nor
thy mate servant nor thy cattle nor thy stranger
that is within thy gates for in six days the lord
made heaven and earth the sea and all that in
them is and rested the seventh day wherefore the
lord blessed us half of the day and hallowed it
honor thy father and their mother that thy days
may be long upon the land which
the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill thou shall not
commit adultery thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness against thy
neighbor thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's house
thou shall not cover thy neighbor's wife nor his
manservant nor his maidservant textual rose on
this side nor his arks nor his ass know anything
that is thy neighbors revelation chapter 14.
and now we're reading from the book of revelation
chapter 14 and i looked and lo a lamb stood on
mount zion and with him a hundred forty
and four thousand having his father's
name written in their foreheads and i heard
a voice from heaven as a voice of many waters
and as a voice of a great thunder and i heard
their voice of hoppers harping with their harps
and they sung as it were a new song before
the throne and before the four beasts
and the elders and no man could learn that
song but the hundred and forty four thousand
which were redeemed from the earth these
are they which were not defiled with women
for their virgins these are they which
follow the lamb with us wherever he goeth
these were redeemed from among men being
the first fruits under god into the lamb
and in their mouth was found no guile for
there without fault before the throne of god
and i saw another angel fly in the midst
of heaven having the everlasting gospel
to preach unto them that dwell on the earth
and to every nation and kindred and tongue and
people saying with a loud voice fear god and give
glory to him for the hour his judgment has come
and worship him that made heaven and earth
and the sea and the fountains of waters
have we overlooked anyone thank you
and there followed another angel saying
babylon has fallen his fall in thy great city
because you made all nations drink of
the wine of the wrath of fornication
and the third angel followed them saying with
a loud voice if any man worship the beast
and his image and receive his mark in his
forehead on his hand the same shall drink of
the wine of the wrath of god which is poured out
without mixture into the cup of his indignation
and he shall be tormented with fire and brimstone
in the presence of the holy angels and the
presence of the lamb and the smoke of the torment
that sends up forever and ever and they have no
rest day and night who worship the beast and his
image and whosoever receives the mark of his name
here is the patience of the saints here
they that keep the commandments of god
and the faith of jesus has anyone
been missed he made the preparation
wherever possible i'd like
us to mean wherever possible
our father in heaven we are people
kneeling your presence this afternoon
lord we thank you that you love us
we thank you for your patience with us
we thank you for your word that
guides us and directs our lives
lord we must take a little while to praise you
for your goodness we say with the psalmist in
psalm 34 1 i will bless the lord at all times
his praise shall be continually in my mouth
and because of your goodness to us father if you
never did anything else for us we can spend the
rest of our lives praising your name because
you have been good and we lift up our voice to
say publicly you are a good god you have blessed
us you have caused us no harm but we have caused
you trouble ah father thank you for being so
good so merciful so righteous a mighty god who
destroys the enemies of his people but also who
punishes his people when they stray from his law
lord we ask you to look upon us with favor
because in heaven next to you is someone
who looks just like us jesus christ our
savior so father we come to you in his
name that you may not see us but see him and
there's nothing you will deny him we know that
lord we have confessed to those whom we have
hurt we have given forgiveness to those who have
hurt us we have tried by your abiding grace if we
confess our sins and put them away and now we come
asking you to do for us what we cannot
do for ourselves and what we confess
we do not deserve lord in the name of
jesus look upon us with mercy compassion
you said in psalm 103 verse 14 like as a
father pity of his children so the lord
pity of them that fear him we kneel
in need of pity from you their father
lord we are spiritually sick and we need
to be restored and healed plain and simple
and our spiritual sickness is not your
fault we hold you innocent and harmless
and we kneel guilty forgive us for that we
pray we can never ask forgiveness too often
lord heal our hearts dig out sin from our
hearts we pray our sickness stems from our
sin root sin out and remove it father
leave no evil root of wickedness in us
remove it root and branch and destroy it let
sin from henceforth be the ashes under our feet
and let our lives be a continual attempt to praise
your name you also said in psalm 103 verse 13
he remembers our frame he knoweth our
frame he remembers that we're dust
lord because we're dust we feel
the aches and pains of our mistakes
and we're asking you now for relief and
deliverance from our physical ailments
lord whatever the disease is the affliction
is the condition is the disability is whatever
the weakness is we ask you in the name of
jesus who healed everyone who came to him
father we ask you in his name to have mercy
upon us and first for your name's sake and
for your glory air indeed for your glory alone
we ask you to place your healing hand upon us
and for the sake of christ and in his name we ask
you lord strengthen our bones put healing into
our bodies lift us up from our affliction we pray
that we will have on our lips a testimony to give
of the mercy of god of the goodness of god father
we cannot command you but we can plead we cannot
tell you but we can bring to you our wishes our
desires heal us from our sickness lord and we say
today if you will do this by your grace we will
live differently according to your laws of health
oh father hear us there's nothing impossible
for you hear us healers restorers strengthen us
but above all save us we pray we offer this prayer
in the name of jesus christ and for his sake let
all god's people say amen and amen we thank you
father we thank you and we praise your holy name
put into our hearts a love for your law
make us obedient people father let us be
able to stand up to the to the ridicule of the
world when we live in obedience to your laws
bless us bless us your good god and we thank
you for that thank you father in jesus name amen
while you're standing and sitting
gentlemen just stay with me if you will
keep in mind in luke chapter
17 jesus met ten lepers
and when he saw them he said unto
them go show yourselves to the priests
because they cried out and said jesus
have mercy on us meaning heal us
most of christ's healings were immediate
that's probably what they thought he'd do
and he does it sometimes but he said
go show yourselves to the priests
the bible says came to pass while they were
on their way you know what that means we
promise god today will obey his laws come on
amen while we are on our way to doing that
some of us will be fully restored some are
probably restored now and you don't know
god may have fixed your kidney your gallbladder
your stomach i don't know but for some of us
it may come while we are on our
way of obedience to his will
a blind man came to jesus once jesus touched
his eyes and he did not see perfectly at once
he said i see men how like trees so what christ
may have done for you now is to give you a start
to show you okay i accept you i forgive you here's
a start now let me see what you do with that style
but i do believe god has been merciful
do you love jesus i love jesus i
love god can you say praise god
let's stand father i know what i have
seen you do from country to country
i have seen it with my eyes
and the power you have overseas
you have here in this land i believe
elohim said no land has been more blessed
that the sun has shone upon than these united
states and you can do your wonders here
lord we believe we accept the greatest
wonder you can do is change your life
so father we thank you for the
demonstration of your power in your way
and we will leave this place
now carrying the conviction
that we must obey you that you may bless
us with health physical and spiritual
lord our worst disease is not disease of the
kidney it's not some disease of the heart it
is the disease of laodicea and i'm asking you
father remove that cancer from us grant us your
spirit grant us the spirit of the apostles and
more grant us the spirit of our pioneers and more
grant us the spirit of daniel and more yeah
grant us the spirit of jesus christ the spirit
that will make us obedient unto death even the
death of the cross grant us that spirit now as
we go the sun has not yet said perhaps keep us
conscious that while anyone can keep the sabbath
only a holy person can keep it holy so let us go
forth holy renewed forgiven and eager to serve we
offer this prayer in jesus name and for his sacred
all god's people say amen amen god bless you
you